de la commission des affaires sociales
où monsieur le rapporteur qui aura
porteur bien merci monsieur le Président
donc
la commission s'est réunie pour
représenter un nouvel amendement contenu
de demande de gouvernement de précision
de coordination je vous le présente et
nous avons réécrit l'article
pour une bonne partie
pour une bonne partie voilà
donc
quelques minutes monsieur le Président
pour présenter cet amendement important
comme l'indique son objet cet amendement
apporte plusieurs précisions à l'article
7 il aménage la rédaction de l'article
l161-17-2 du code de la sécurité sociale
afin d'y préserver la base légale
relative à l'âge d'ouverture des droits
des assurés nés avant le premier
septembre 1961 tout en conservant bien
sûr le principe d'un relèvement
progressif de l'âge d'ouverture des
droits à 64 ans pour ceux né à compter
du 1er septembre 1961 il codifie les
dispositions relatives à la montée en
charge de l'âge de départ applicable aux
militaire qui ne justifie pas de la
durée de service exemptant de conditions
d'âge il procède à diverses
rectifications d'erreurs matériels
coordination ou clarification
rédactionnelle
il intègre l'amendement du Gouvernement
prévoyant que la mise en œuvre du
nouveau dispositif de maintien en
fonction jusqu'à l'âge de 70 ans pour
les fonctionnaires n'entraîne pas la
radiation des cadres des personnes
concernées
il précise des modalités d'entrée en
vigueur de la mesure de report de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits à 64 ans ainsi
que son application dans les
collectivités
ultramarines enfin il reprend les
demandes exprimées par plusieurs groupes
d'une clause de revoyure d'ici à 2027
il s'agit donc vous le voyez d'apporter
de nombreuses précisions que nous
jugeons utiles au sein de cet article
par ailleurs monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
du fait de sa rédaction il est de quelle
nature à clarifier les débats
en effet
en effet il va permettre au Sénat de se
prononcer d'un blog sur les paramètres
essentiels de cet article 7
dont nous avons déjà amplement débattus
depuis 19h et à vrai dire depuis le
début de nos travaux jeudi dernier
le Sénat veut-il oui ou non qu'à compter
du premier septembre 2023 l'âge
d'ouverture des droits soit
progressivement relevée jusqu'à
atteindre 64 ans pour la génération 1968
le
Sénat veut-il oui ou non une
accélération de la mise en œuvre de la
réforme Touraine
afin
vous allez dire oui vous afin que la
durée de cotisation requise pour
l'obtention du taux plein soit porté à
43 années à partir de la génération 1965
[Musique]
notre vote sur cet amendement permettra
à chacun de nous d'exprimer clairement
sa position et de trancher ce débat
essentiel
son adoption
ferait tomber plus de 1100 amendements
qui se répartissent
pour l'essentiel en deux catégories
premièrement
des amendements tendons à introduire des
dérogations par métier
587 amendements
n'oubliez pas n'oubliez pas dans ces
amandes blancs là de retirer celui qui
concerne les bornes d'âge de 62 à 64 ans
pour les internes en médecine
des amendements de replis des
amendements de suppression d'articles on
en a déjà eu quelques-uns me semble-t-il
tendance à supprimer des alinés à du
texte 517
mais mais je vous rassure
même après l'éventuelle adoption de
cette amendement
il nous restera vous voyez que vous avez
tout prévu il nous restera un débat
riche suscept article 7
puisqu'ils d'amendements de tous les
groupes politiques qui nous permettront
des débats de fonds sur des sujets
importants notamment la situation des
maires de famille la situation des
sportifs de haut niveau le rachat de
trimestre d'études supérieures et des
périodes de stage les conditions de
départ en retraite des enseignants ou
encore des sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels la commission sera même
favorable à l'adoption de plusieurs de
ses amendements là encore venant de
différents groupes et il nous restera
évidemment un débat riche sur tous les
articles qui suivront
je vous remercie de votre attention et
vous appelez évidemment à bien vouloir
voter en faveur de cet amendement de la
commission
l'homme la présidente
[Applaudissements]
oui monsieur assoline si vous pouvez
éviter de crier derrière ce serait ce
serait plus sympathique et surtout ça
devient fatigant en application
l'article 46 bis alinéa 2 du règlement
ce n'est pas en hurlant qu'on se fait le
mieux entendre et qu'on est le plus
intelligible donc voilà
en application l'article 46b c'est un
deux du règlement la Commission à voter
en ce sens et propose au Sénat de 10
juin l'amendement numéro
4762 de la discussion commune merci
alors
c'est bien une demande de priorité
ça voté par la Commission et je demande
en application de l'article 44 alinéa 6
du règlement la priorité d'examen et de
vote sur cet amendement
bien je suis donc saisi du demande de
priorité de la commission afin qu'ils
soient mis aux voix avant l'ensemble des
amendements de la discussion commune je
rappelle pour l'organisation de nos
débats c'est l'article 44 aligné à 6 de
notre règlement la priorité de droit
quand elle est demandée par la
Commission saisie au fond à moins que le
gouvernement s'y oppose le gouvernement
de s'y oppose pas
merci à monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président
et je note monsieur le Président mais
vous l'avez fait avant moi et avant la
suspension qu'il y a eu plus de 120
interventions sur cet article et je note
aussi pour avoir regardé rapidement
évidemment l'amendement tel que l'adopté
par la commission des affaires sociales
que cet amendement va permettre et va
nous permettre s'il est adopté bien sûr
de discuter débattre de plusieurs
dizaines d'amendements qui pensent sur
des sujets de fonds des sujets
importants permettant de progresser sur
l'article 7 pour la visionction la vie
du gouvernement n'est pas requis je
crois monsieur le Président et donc
évidemment le Gouvernement s'en remet la
décision du Sénat et pour ce qui
concerne la priorité traditionnellement
et par
usage mais aussi par respect des travaux
du Sénat le Gouvernement s'en remet
aussi au Sénat donc je considère que le
gouvernement de s'oppose pas la priorité
est donc de droit et
je vais maintenant vous faire demander
l'application de l'article 46 sur la
demande par la commission d'examens
séparés de l'amendement je vais
consulter là le Sénat s'il y a des
observations
madame la Présidente
président comme nous nous y attendions
également
voilà la réécriture de cette article 7
nous avons bien évidemment parce que
nous sommes courageux monsieur Lemoine
qui est parti
nous avons bien évidemment travaillé des
sous amendements et donc je vous remets
je remets au service de la séance les
sous amendements que mon groupe a vient
dépose pour
l'examen de cette réécriture de
l'article 7
ça veut dire que
je vais consulter néanmoins pour savoir
qui est pour
cette demande de disjonction donc ceux
qui sont pour le manifestant devant la
main
avis contraire abstention et vous allez
pouvoir nous remettre les sous
amendements
et ce qui va m'amener madame la
Présidente à ce que la Commission se
remette au travail pour un certain temps
pour un certain temps monsieur le
Président donc je demande en effet une
suspension de séance pour réunir la
commission pour examiner les quelques on
parle de 3000
trop bien
vous verrez le chiffre en arrivant ça se
pèse
et donc
trois quarts
nous reprendrons à deux heures 45 voilà
donc je rappelle que la séance sera
reprise elle est suspendue à deux heures
ce qui permet à chaque prendre des
forces